Media right media as you know it's a
very special word or medium it's a very
special word in this course right so
we've got like multi media and the media
data types and so on and so forth right
here I'm using media in the general
sense of the word
okay what did we say medium what do we
say admit that in general terms and
you've got small that you've got large
and we call the other size medium why do
we call it medium that's exactly right
it just it just fits in between it's not
because medium is a word to do with size
it has nothing to do with size which is
why you've got like you know spirits and
mediums and that kind of thing it just
means in between so when you have a look
once down this list okay and I see
stands for network interface carbage is
the first one I'm going to do cables of
backbones repeaters model all of these
things right I'll well rather none of
these things are nodes okay
they're not nodes they're the things
that go in between nodes not birds but
in between
okay so in other words if you were to
make up a network and it had all of
these cool things which I'm gonna
explain to you in a second if there add
all of these every single to list it
would still not be a network because
would have no nodes attached to it
that's been weird isn't it let me try
and explain so we're going to get
through and I try and explain what all
of these bits are if you like it's kind
of like infrastructure so I suppose I
could have called this network
infrastructure once infrastructure does
anyone know it in front feet in front we
usually hear it we usually hear when
describe to a color namely infra red
right it already taught infrared is
invisible but it doesn't mean invisible
missin or not the opposite of infrared
is it's ultraviolet infrared ultraviolet
so the idea is that the color spectrum
the visible color spectrum then the
lowest colors red then the highest color
is violet and then the other stuff on
this side is infra red and the stuff on
this side is ultra violet so what do you
think infrared ultra mean they just mean
infrared means this red and he's always
stuffed below red right so infra beats
below and ultraviolet UV right it means
he is violet and here's all the stuff
above violet so infra structure means
structure that's underneath and
supporting all the other stuff and makes
it work okay so maybe no infrastructure
would have been a better name right so
let's go through and try and explain
each bit I said the first one is called
an ni C or a network interface card
network
okay let me show
okay sorry well we got to network
interface card
okay so network you guys know a network
is by now right you're probably six
different interface what does that mean
it means it lets you connect two things
together so it's literally like when
you're having face-to-face conversation
with someone right that's you could say
interface conversation with someone
because it's between two phases are you
not international means between nations
right so interface means you have two
things they're facing each other and the
network interface card is the thing that
goes in between okay that's why I was
getting at this idea of its media it's
in between stuff okay so all of the
computers you've got if you can connect
it to a network you need this this thing
here and it's called a card because it's
literally an electronics chip a separate
card that you plug into your computer
and it you can take it out and connect
and you can actually all see the network
interface card on your computers from
the outside did you know that you can
either take one of these
B computers and turn it around a little
or you can get your laptop and pick it
up okay and I want you to look for on
the outside there's a little point it
kind of looks like this either this or
upside down okay it's where you would
plug in your network cable okay or your
Ethernet cable and we call it Ethernet
port okay now what this is is one end of
the network interface card okay that's
why you can plug a network into it